hi
everyone my name is frank yoo
today i'm very happy to share
one of my work learning and strongly
truthful multitask peer predictions
a variational approach this is a joint
work with grand genomics
so the problem that we're trying to
solve is how can we elicit information
from crowds who or strategics
in particular we're trying to make sure
that agents
are willing to share the information
truthfully
and oftentimes it will be very difficult
for us to verify this whether agents are
telling us the truth or not
so agents agents
this is due to multiple reasons first
first of all a lot of time idiom signals
are subjective
for example if you're trying to ask
whether you are happy or do you like
certain restaurants
it will be it is only
this signal will be only possible for
those agents
on the other hand their signal could be
private
for example you may want to ask why is
your commute times in that way it will
be very difficult for us to
to even observe that so
one main idea of this area is is called
peer predictions so the main idea is
that
people are connected and their signals
are dependent
so take the commute time as example
if we knows that if we're trying to
collect the common time for ls above
because the communal route have some
overlapping and not
overlapping if we know uh
ns commute times this will give us some
information about bob's coming times
and in that way we can use that to
verify whether bob is
telling us the truth or not given
address is true still lives
so the question of these papers
to put it more formally we're trying to
encourage people to report their
signatures fully
and we consider a multi-test setting
that is
we have multiple uh for example we're
trying to collect
um agents daily commute times so for
each days
alice and bob will get their own signal
at day i
as forget x i and bob would get y i
and they may manipulate their reports
and we're trying to come up with a
payment which mapping from their reports
to the payments to them and we want to
make sure that
agents are incentivized to report
truthfully so to make to make it more
formal we're trying to design a strongly
trustful mechanism
that is true telling itself it's a
bayesian nationalist
so lis saying that suppose alice
tells us the truth um
bob would be also incentivized to tell
us the truth as well
moreover we wish that the truth telling
have the highest payments
that is if agents do any manipulation or
they agree on some
uninformative strategy they can only
make their payment to be less
so in particular for our strong
nutritional mechanism we ensure that
the choosing have the highest payments
and
and if all the payment outer strategy
will have the same payment then
it's basically just a permutations
equilibrium that is
agents are promoting their their reports
in that ways we can also uh we can still
reconstruct that
uh the reports and without any use of
information
so in these areas the multitask peer
prediction there is
a long line of work which use
like a mutual information framework uh
this framework is
proposed by kong genovex
uh i'll call it mutual information
framework
which saying that if you can pay the
agent the mutual informations between
digital reports then we can design
a very good mechanism given some
assumption on the
joint distributions so using these
ideas using this framework
this can contain a lot of previous work
as a special case
for example the original work by the
scuba and gauche
assuming that their signals are binary
and positive correlative
name
it can be reduced to mutual formations
which we are going to illustrate uh
later
and similarly schneider at all and all
girls can see
the binary signal space to discrete
uh categorical signals and they
propose a correlated agreement making
sense however their mechanism
is not strongly truthful but only
achieve a weaker notion
and additionally kong engine banks
considers the mechanism who can
which can
so the co-training mechanisms
collect agents prediction of latent
state instead of their signal
and they can also seem as a special case
of
computing agent's mutual information
between their
sequence
and there's also other approach which we
are not going to
cover uh for example the determinant
mechanisms by cones which pays agents
the determinants of their joint
distributions
and they can achieve a dominant truthful
when their signal
are finite and
require some strong but require some
stronger assumptions
of joint distributions and similarly
chance at a chance at all propose a
shift
surrogate scoring rule which also
limited to
finance signal space
so in in this talk uh we are we're
trying to make connections to to these
uh existing metric mechanisms using this
mutual information framework
in particular if we want if we use the
vendorograms the mutual information
framework contents
are all previous as a special case
and our parenting mechanisms
intuitively contains the existing
multi-test mechanism as a special case
but it's a special case of a mutual
information framework
and our contributions have like tooth to
to float
to fold the first one is our approach
enable us to work on a much more general
signal space
all existing work are limited to
uh finance signal space that is you can
only report like
connect binary signals or finance
signals
we our approach we can
make our making some work on continuous
signal or even arbitrary measurable
uh signaling major growth space
and furthermore we make the
uh connections of mechanical designs and
learnings
uh transparent and these enable
us to use like a state-of-art mechanism
to
state of ordering algorithm to help us
to diff uh design the bayesian
mechanisms
so uh we are going to focus more on
how does our mechanism connect to the
existing ones and if you are interested
in the connection to the learning part
i'll be very happy to talk to you during
the conference or
later so here is the outline
uh we are first going to illustrate
what is the mutual information framework
for pure predictions
and then we are going to talk about how
can we use a variation of statistics
for mutual formations to design a much
robust
mechanisms and
finally we are going to
summarize and compare our mechanisms to
the existing ones so first uh our
what is the mutual formation framework
so before going to that uh i need to
uh emphasize or stress on quite certain
assumption age in the multitask setting
and this assumption is used in all
existing work
so it consists of two very important
parts
the first is a prior singular test
that is we consider for example if you
want to collect the daily commute time
we consider the signals of agents the
areas has
signal ns above signals are id
distributed across all the tasks
so there's a common pxy which generates
errors above each day's signals
and the second assumption is a uniform
strategy or
consistent strategy this requires that
alice later strategy can be encoded as a
random
markov operators from each day signal to
their each day's report
and the strategy between each days
are identical and independent okay
so under these two assumptions uh
well we are ready to define the mutual
formation
so the idea is that
if we can measure some kind of distance
such that the distance between
agent signals will be always larger than
uh many uh agents the district between
agents
reports so that is if you apply any
strategy
then the distance between um
their proofs will become smaller okay
so uh
so this is the main observations is that
you can understand you can understand
the strategy as a signal that is a noisy
signal in the information theory
that is given a signal x what areas can
do
is just make their the report
more noisy and that's correlated with
bob's
signals because alice only have the
information
about her signals so that is you can
consider
any strategy is a noisy channel theta a
which apply on her own information
and the
the random variable y x and x hat
forms the markov chains
so with this observation we can
just use uh uh we can there there's a
data processing quality for us to use
that is if you major the mutual
formations
channel mutual formation between x and y
it will be always
larger than the channel mutual formation
between
y and x hat
and and
these will satisfy our
ideal uh our leads will be served as a
decent functions between agency reports
and will be useful for us to design the
mechanism
so note uh so
here notice that uh the mutual mutual
formations only depends on
joint distributions of any signals and
the product of
the module and
actually the data processing quality can
be applied to
a larger family of functions
which is called mutual formations or
find mutual formations depend on
different literature
then you you basically saying that given
any
convex function phi uh we can define a
phi mutual formulation according to
the phi of this probability ratio
and if you compute these terms then
the mutual formations between their
signal will be always greater than the
mutual function between the reports
so with these observations
we can if we can pay agents in the
mutual formations
then the truth tellings will be always
larger than
the non-truth-telling equilibrium or
strategy profiles
so the problem will reduce to how can we
estimate these mutual formations
so the mutual information from rubix is
saying that
if you can major if you can measure
the five mutual information speaking
agents report
under certain conditions then
you can you can the resulting mechanism
will be strongly truthful
and the problem will be
reduced to how can we estimate the
mutual formation
and if you look at the definition of the
fine mutual information you will notice
that
it will be sufficient for us to compute
the
joint joint distribution pxy
which can be easily estimated
by pairs of reports on common tasks
that is the purple one and
for the green distribution you can
estimate that
by a pairs of reports on distinct text
and if you have large number uh if you
have
uh enough numbers uh enough
tasks then you can use a just report to
estimate
these mutual formations given they are
just telling us
moreover if agents manipulate
their reports then what we get
is the distributions of their
manipulated reports and we can get
the mutual formation between their their
reports
and by data processing quality we can we
have
the resulting payments will be smaller
than
the payment of the truth telling which
is the mutual information between their
signals
so are we done with that uh if we have
enough number of tests then everything
will be fine
however in our paper we shows that when
your m is finite then things will get
complicated
and actually it's much more complicated
so first of all there's no unbiased
estimator for five mutual formations
and this will make will
cause us issues and instead of its
extraordinary truthful mechanism we can
only get approximately
approximately version of that
uh furthermore if you want to get a good
approximated uh
approximated strongly crucial mechanism
it requires the estimation estimating
the arrows is uniformly bounded
in particular if agents apply arbitrary
strategy
you still need to ensure your estimation
is
accurate this will be
particular uh this will be number
this is very limited when we consider
your information your report
is in a very large space for example
continuous one
because whenever you fix your mechanisms
the agents can always agrees on
very bad strategies such that your
mechanisms
perform poorly on those strategic
behaviors
so this will make the guarantee become
not not not possible
not meaningful when your test is
finished
so so our
our so we introduced the variational
statistics
to to solve these problems
so the idea is very simple it's already
known
a lot of different areas we can use
uh young's furniture inequalities
to convert the convex function 5 to an
optimization problems with respect to
the complex conjugate by star
so the find mutual formation is
basically
it will be related to this convex
function
if we apply young's venturing quality
term wise then we can translate the
mutual formations into an optimization
and optimization problem in particular
the optimizations would would be over
a space of a functional which may bring
from a pair
of pairs of reports to the scores
and we will call this function k as a
scoring functions
and the maximum the maximum what happens
at
k star which will depend which will
depends on the ratios of the joint
distribution and the product fundamental
solutions
and we call this maximizer
as an idea of scoring functions so here
is some example
if we consider here some
here are some examples of the idea of
scrolling rule if we consider the
signals are simple for
our join gaussians in the first columns
and in discussions i centered around
zero and it's
uh some is
is positive related and then in that
case
if we consider uh
using phi equal to
phi a equal to a log a then
uh the resulting mutual formation will
be channel mutual formation
and then our score ideal school rule
will be a quadratic functions
on the other hand if you take phi a
equal to
absolute value of a minus 1 then the
resulting
ideal score rule would be a binary value
would be a zero one functions and
the values will be uh eclipse
and within the within the eclipse you
will get
one and outside will get zeros so uh
depending on your parametric uh on your
model of information ah you can design
a good you can pick a good fight
such that the resulting ideal scoring
rule is
is good so
after we make these decompositions uh
we can we can we can estimate the mutual
information
so so
in here we have three parts first is we
want to ask me the ideal score rule
and this we can expand this one by
first partition part of agent's reports
to test for learning and using that
to estimate our ideal score
and secondly we need to estimate the
joint distributions
and in this way we can just
simple pxy for a pair of reports on a
common task
so this is we call this a bonus task
and thirdly uh we we need a sample of
the green distribution which will be
also easy
to derive when we collect
a pair of reports on distinct text
so given k star the purple
sample of the purple distribution and
support green distribution
we can estimate the fine mutual
information between agents reports
so this is basically our mechanism we
first partition the tasks
into learning and payment and the
learning test we learn the idea score
rule
and in a payment task we pay
we pick a correlated test which we call
it bonus test
and pay the agent by the k on these
quality
tests minus
5 star on the k on the
distinct task so you can think it as a
regularized version of the payments
and people would like to be correlated
and if they
doing something very extremes they are
going to be punished
in the later terms
so uh why bother to make these big
uh complications when we can just use
the
empirical risk risk uh we can just use
the
empirical distribution to pay to compute
the
mutual formation so the big reasons to
do that
to do these complications is that
um we uh look
the arrows is in one direction so in
particular
the maximus what happens if i know
uh only if both the scoring rule is
ideal
and agents reports are truthful
and
and this will implies that
when agents reports are untruthfully
and such that the resulting estimations
perform badly uh perform
valid this will make their payment even
uh to be to be worse
so this will solve
the issues that we pointed out
previously that
we do not require uniform as
we do not need to have a very good
estimating function
uh algorithms for all possible
strategies
space will only require our learning
always
have a good estimations and truth
telling
and this will be a much more
reasonable assumptions in real life
now uh let me finish this by
making some comments on how does our
mechanisms
related to existing one and in
particular how
let me explain the same diagram in more
detail
so first first of all our parody making
sense
plays an approximation of the mutual
information so
this can be seen as a special case of a
mutual information framework
and second of all if we consider
a special case of phi a which is a minus
one steps
let the absolute value of a minus one
then the resulting fine mutual formation
will be the total relational distance
in particular the 5 star will be a
linear
when the increase between
-1 and 1. and in that way
our payments will be will have a much
more simpler form
which is the scoring rule on common task
minus scoring rule on two distinct tests
and this will be uh
this will be indeed the ca making sense
by
the scorpion uh by vice named sniders
and moreover if we assume the signal are
binary and positive correlated then
the resulting ideal scoring functions
will be
1 whenever they report agreed and 0
and minus 1 when they are not when they
report or not
so in this way we we can
uh our mechanism reduce to
the discrimination mechanisms
and this would be uh so so our mechanism
contains these two as a special case
and for co-training mechanisms
they require agents to report their
predictions on
latent variables and they also use this
common task and testing test approach
to derive the ideal scoring rules
from agents reports and
i'm going i'm going to avoid the detail
here
but in general like their mechanism can
be
also seen as a special case of artists
so thank you and this is uh
this is the end of the talk and i'm
looking forward to discuss with you in a
conference
thank you